ce soir les élus de la ville de tours
doivent valider le tracé de la seconde
ligne de tramway qui doit relier
chambray al arich
les discussions s'annoncent longues et
âpres pour obtenir un consensus avec un
passage par jean jaurès et le boulevard
béranger
ce que l'on sait moins c'est que pour
réaliser ce tramway il va falloir faire
des acquisitions foncières et parfois
même exproprier des personnes dont les
biens pourrait empiéter sur le tracé
c'est le cas d'un habitant de la riche
qui vit rue de la mairie un comble pour
lui car il a déjà dû se séparer de son
appartement en face de la gare de tours
lors de la création de la première ligne
de tram aurélie renouveau moi j'ai été
convié au service de l'urbanisme et on
m'a complètement montré un plan
cadastral
on m'a mis un stylo sur le plan
cadastral et on m'a dit toute la partie
du bâtiment là allait sauter pour le
tram ce bâtiment frédéric la rénover
avec ses parents l'ensemble situé sur
leur propriété dunn rue de la mairie à
l'intérieur trois studios qui l'ont mis
en location afin d'assurer un complément
de retraite et finalement bah je vais
peut-être pas avoir de retraite parce
qu'on va me piquer la partie de vente
chez moi où il ya des locations alors
j'ai aucun montant parce que j'ai rien
écrit on n'est même pas venu m'évaluer
des biens donc pour l'instant pas de
nouvelles
voir leurs propriétés coupé en deux un
coup très dur pour la famille qui a
acquis cette maison il y à 25 ans pour
arminda la mère de frédéric l'arrivée du
tramway sur la propriété est
inenvisageable
d'autant que son époux décédé il y a
huit mois avait travaillé très dur pour
rénover l'ensemble amant paris qui a
tout fait deux morts un père détail des
faits rapportés
il nous a dit faut défendre ce qu'il a
fait pour la future expropriation passe
mal d'autant que la famille de frédéric
s'était déjà retrouvé dans cette
situation avec un appartement
qu'ils avaient acquis à tour c'était
pour la première ligne de tram
lors de la construction à côté de la
gare rue de nantes
on n'avait été aussi expropriés ça s'est
mal passé parce que ils nous ont évalué
le bien être un montant et on était
obligé d'être quatre fois au tribunal
pour faire évoluer notre bien quoi
finalement on a gagné on a eu gain de
cause parce qu'ils nous ont remonté la
valeur du bien frédéric se dit prêt à
défendre son dossier pour que
l'évaluation du bâtiment soit correct sa
mère elle n'envisage pas de déménager de
cette propriété qui représente 25 ans de
souvenirs